All right, before we end this lesson,
I want to think about where things like buttons and labels are coming from.
When we make apps for iOS, we can choose from one of many building blocks or
frameworks that are available to us.
One of these, is called UI Kit.
Let me bring it out.
Now you probably noticed that we imported this framework on the top of our code.
Inside UIKit, we have classes like UIView.
This helps us create a rectangular area on the phone,
where we can create content.
We also have another class called UIButton, this helps us make a button.
And finally we have another class called UILabel.
This helps us create labels.
There are a few links in the instructor notes that will give you a list of
all classes inside UIKit and the relationships between those classes.
This includes a helpful image, that lists out all the classes, and
how they are connected.
I encourage you to browse through those links now.